tsingtao hello I'm very glad to welcome
you to our home please come in foil
about my name is bao nguyen tuan bow
this is our house I'd like to introduce
my wife con boy we've lived in this
house for 40 years would we not be
attending a night I did my eldest son
lives above us lezyne and my youngest
below us
ok this is a crossbow and ethnic
minority them long from hua Ben Madon
they gave me the weapon as a present
when I visited wha been in Vietnamese
history we've often fought against
enemies from the outside the crossbow
like this used to be a very dangerous
weapon he said let hi but in our home we
have lots of pictures that I like very
much this one here for instance tells us
something about Vietnamese history to
zola pitch awards at la la noia Vietnam
the object at the rear of the pager is
the Dow pagoda one of the oldest pagodas
in Vietnam and there's a typical
vietnamese market yeah but then huh
night I in our free time we like to look
at photos from the time when we were in
germinated late I had though in a that's
me I was also on a football team back
then
yeah the LT doesn't know this is our
schnapps container just about every
Vietnamese family has one like this
schnapps is distilled from glutinous
rice in Vietnam we also put a special
kind of Vietnamese apple into it the
older the shops the better it tastes we
drink it with our meals on holidays like
New Year's or day of the dead sweet
bullet does that boy you babe we're
really pleased that you visited our
family goodbye till next time